[Musique]
tous
bonjour brigitte lahaie soyez la
bienvenue et merci de me recevoir
on dit ravi que vous soyez là est ce que
vous considérez comme une femme engagée
n'a pas forcément non mais en tout cas
je reste je reste fidèle à moi même à
mes convictions j'ai en ce sens
peut-être que je suis en effet quelqu'un
d'engagé je crois ça vous surprend qu'on
vous invite dans une émission qui parle
de l'engagement
alors oui au départ ça m'a surprise
parce que j'ai pas là j'ai pas le
sentiment d'avoir fait des choses
d'engagement comme comme certain par
exemple qui vont diriger une association
etc et en même temps c'est vrai que si
je regarde mon parcours je me suis
d'abord engagé avec mon corps
aujourd'hui je m'engage avec la voix et
je reste
oui je défende je défends toujours cette
cette liberté d'être cette liberté
sexuelle et c'est ce qu'on va parcourir
votre tout premier engagement c'est donc
dans le cinéma porno je cite par
exhibitionnisme voyeurisme et plaisir
franchement je voulais d'y être capable
de le penser et de le dire comme ça mais
c'est extraordinaire mais c'est toujours
la même chose je crois que quand on a
quand on a la chance de de dire les
choses telles qu on les ressent et de
savoir l'assumer parce que finalement
très souvent on ne va pas dire ce qu'on
pense parce que parce qu'on a peur du
regard de l'eau et parce qu'on a peur
d'eux mais moi si vous voulez quand j'ai
commencé à parler de ma carrière
pornographiques j'avais déjà arrêté et
j'avais j'avais décidé que je n'allais
rien renier parce que je ne voulais pas
me renier oui et je crois que c'est ça
qui a été ma force je dis pas que ç'a
toujours été facile mais en tout cas ça
a été ma force
et aujourd'hui je suis ce que je suis et
les tant pis si ce duo nous enfin je
veux dire tant pis tant mieux ça va
toujours on arrive toujours à s'entendre
avec ce qu'ils nous apprécient mais il
faut il faut s'en [__] de ceux qui ne
sont pas d'accord avec nous de ceux qui
ne pensent pas comme nous de ceux qui
voudraient que ça change parce que de
toute façon on ne peut être bien dans sa
peau qu en étant fidèle à soi même et en
étendant son vrai désir ça c'est quand
même déjà du courage et c'est déjà dans
l'engagement
peut-être que j'ai pensé comme vous que
j'avais envie d'être exhibitionnistes ou
voyeuriste ou quoi que ce soit en tout
cas moi j'ai pas eu le courage de le
dire lit de l'assumer ni le faire
c'est donc bel et bien d'un engagement
oui oui en tout cas en tout cas l'an
pour moi pour moi l'engagement c'est pas
d'avoir fait du porno c'est d'avoir su
ne pas le renier le défendre et et
ensuite je me suis rendu compte que ça
avait été quand même un engagement parce
qu'on ait fait plein de gens parce
qu'ils ont envie dans les films parce
qu'ils m'ont entendu ce sont autorisés
un peu plus de liberté sexuelle
quand vous faites ce choix de faire du
cinéma porno quant à un moment vous
revendiquez célibataire quand vous dites
aussi mais moi j'ai choisi de ne pas
avoir d'enfant est ce que à chaque fois
ce que vous dites c'est que vous refusez
d'être assigné en tout cas je refuse que
là je refuse de me sentir obligé d'être
dans la norme et
et je veux je veux assumer ma différence
oui et je la revendique
vous savez moi moi quand dont 85 87
l'époque où justement j'avais déjà
arrêté le porno et on invitait beaucoup
sur les plateaux télé quand je disais et
une femme peut très bien avoir du
plaisir avec un homme qu'elle n'aime pas
ça faisait scandale il ya deux ans je
dis malheureusement une femme peut jouir
lors d'un violent c'est pareil ça fait
scandale mais en même temps ça fait
avancer les choses
oui et c'est peut-être ça mais vous
savez on me dit souvent que j'ai du
courage moi je veux toujours rappeler
l'étymologie du mot courage ça vient du
coeur et j'aime mieux dire que je suis
une femme je suis une femme qui aime qui
aimes tu m'aimes d'abord parce que je
crois qu'il faut il faut un certain négo
pour être dans l'engagement
et puis je suis une femme qui aime thiem
la vie qui aiment les autres et qui a
envie de communiquer de transmettre au
sein est ce que ça a toujours été le cas
est-ce que à 20 ans vous êtes déjà comme
ça quelqu'un qui aime et qui va parce
que vous êtes libre de vous affranchir
je suis très bluffé par sa de
s'affranchir d'une culture d'une
religion peut-être d'une éducation
certainement c'est c'est très spécial et
il y avait un feu un feu fort en moi et
j'avais j'avais envie de le laisser
s'exprimer dans un de vos livres vous
dites que vous avez fait ça pour des
fusionner avec votre mère oui j'avais
une relation
j'ai eu une très belle relation à ma
mère d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs je lui
dois je lui dois mon bon sens je lui
dois 7,7 sécurité intérieure je lui dois
beaucoup de choses mais
mais elle et elle était très
zain prix impliquer un briquet dans une
culture très très petite bourgeoisie
donc certainement pas été facile pour
elle ce n'est pas une femme libre non
non non mais c'est notre époque aussi c
est difficile d'être une femme libre
mais même à mon époque d'ailleurs rien
entendu et à la mienne et ce peut-être
encore difficile aujourd'hui d'être des
insurgés aux portes mais il y en a pour
qui c'est plus difficile que pour
d'autres y en a pour qui c'est plus
facile que pour d'autres est ce que pour
vous ça a été plus facile ou en tout cas
plus irrépressible que pour d'autres en
tous cas
en tout cas ça a été très vite
indispensable pour moi d'être libre et
quel âge quand vous dites très vite
c'est quoi ces camps 23 24 ans pour la
première fois je quitte moi j'ai eu une
vie passionnée amoureuse aussi très
riche et la première fois que je quitte
un homme que j'aime et pourtant c'était
justement parce que à un moment donné je
me rendais compte que il entrave est ma
liberté donc je suis parti j'ai lu aussi
dans un de vos livres que votre père
s'était dit fier de la manière je cite
donc vous avez utilisé votre capital
physique c'est assez peu conventionnelle
que les réflexions
c'est vrai mais mon père je les
suffrages tout ça on le découvre après
quand on commence à travailler un peu
sur soi mon père en fait était passionné
de de sexualité il avait le rapport avec
le rapport kinsey dans sa bibliothèque
il avait des curieuses à
et tout ça moi j'ai découvert après donc
je pense que il était certainement
passionné par la légende bataille dans
ses livres enfin il est plein de choses
mais ça veut dire qu'il a vu vos films
je ne pense pas un jeu c'est pas
forcément j'ai jamais posé la question
c'est vrai mais je pense pas non je
pense pas de départ en ait envie de voir
leur civile en plein ébat sexuel non
j'imagine pas mais en fait j'avais
associés ça mais effectivement vous avez
raison peut-être que c'est juste l'idée
de votre liberté qui lui a plu quand
même quelqu'un d'assez ces intellectuels
enfin le cérébral disons donc je pense
que c'était plus la lecture érotique il
autres passionnés que la vision alors
vous parler de littérature justement il
ya une émission qui a compté dans votre
votre histoire un moment donné si une
invitation à la télévision dans
l'émission de bernard pivot
cette émission s'appelle apostrophe on
va regarder un petit bout parce que le
mot indécence un sens
un très beau pour moi toute façon la
décence et je crois je crois qu'à ma
manière c'est vrai que je choque c'est
vrai que je suis peut-être indécence
indécent pardon mais c'est ma façon de
17 ans géré l'excès mais peut-être joué
vous descente ma question
j'ai pas osé vous dire mais c'est
vraiment on en est toujours là
aujourd'hui à questionner l'indécence de
jeu je crois qu'on est on est on est
toujours assez assez gêné de parler de
sa sexualité
je pense que ça reste toujours quelque
chose de compliqué et ce que je constate
surtout puisque moi j'écoute tous les
jours des gens parler de sexualité
je constate qu'on parle finalement très
peu de sa sexualité à qui que ce soit
même pas à son partenaire d'ailleurs et
c'est d'ailleurs un des problèmes de
couple
ça vous elle a été important de cette
émission elle a été essentielle oui elle
a été essentielle parce que quand ce
livre sort moi la scandaleuse
je pense que
l'émission apostrophes de bernard pivot
lui a donné sorte de crédibilité et le
livre du coup a été reçue
enfin du coup j'ai le livre s'est très
bien vendu j'ai été reçu dans énormément
d'émissions de télé parce qu'on pouvait
m'inviter j'étais passé apostrophe je
suis pas sûr pour mon cerveau est vu
autant de répercussions sans cet alibi
culturel
c'est étonnant vous dites que c'est le
livre qui a une crédibilité moi je pense
que c'est vous qui avez eu une
crédibilité au final 1 oui enfin
enfin si nous disons que puisque ça m'a
invité à apostrophes on pouvait
m'inviter en 87 j'ai quand même eu
encore parfois des
des refus j'étais encore la scandaleuse
oui encore ce qu'on ne voulait plus non
je n'en quand est-ce que ça a cessé je
crois que c'est là c'est une émission
sur rmc maintenant sur sud radio xm
radio vous écoutez les auditeurs on est
dans un an et absolument ça a été ça a
été assez loin il a fallu de trois ans
de radio avant que ça cesse
c'est face les diabolisent est ce que
vous savez ce que c'est qu'une femme
libre comment vous qualifieriez vous une
femme libre c'est d'abord une femme qui
sait les douaniers de sa mère ce qui
n'est pas une mince affaire
parce que beaucoup de femmes deviennent
comme leur mère ou à l'opposé de leur
mère donc ça c'est déjà la première
grand écueil que rencontrent les femmes
que ne rencontre pas les hommes parce
que les hommes de par leur sexe
différent déjà se dédouane de leur mère
et on entend toujours le le fils qui
reste accroché à maman mais non c'est
vraiment une grande difficulté pour les
femmes donc ça c'est déjà la première
chose ensuite il faut savoir qu'est ce
qui est important pour nous dans la vie
moi si je suis un peu agacé de ce
discours qu'on entend qu'une femme
aujourd'hui peut tout faire peut être
une roumaine wonder women une femme
élevant ses enfants une femme dont je
crois que je crois qu'on a que 24 heures
et il faut faire le choix de de ce conte
de ce qui est essentiel pour nous et
ensuite sur la question de la sexualité
les femmes sont encore beaucoup dans le
désir de l'homme et elles attendent
elles attendent beaucoup de lui il ya
des tas de choses qui sont les enfants
qui sont importantes à la comprendre
si nous mêmes en tant que femme on ne
sait pas s'ouvrir ne s'est pas connaître
son corps on pourra jamais accédé à une
sexualité qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
libres et donc ça c'est encore un tabou
c'est encore compliqué de l'approché
s'est encore compliqué de le dire alors
je dois encore une fois moi je ne sais
pas si c'est inné cissé a qu'ici c'est
dans la 6 et comme le dit la
psychanalyse dans la dent dans la dans
la féminité que d'être passive tout ça
moi j'en sais rien ce que je peux juste
dire c'est qu'à l'instant t c'est à dire
en 2000
20 on est on est encore dans cette dans
ce schéma là oui beaucoup de femmes
attendent
on est encore la belle au bois dormant
qui est maintenant le baiser du prince
charmant pour s'éveiller à la sexualité
je ris parce qu'avec l'équipe on a
trouvé une image de vous qui résume je
crois mais alors mais profondément ce
que vous êtes et c'est une image d'une
liberté mais un sens et alors c'est pas
du tout la belle au bois dormant vous
avez une idée de ce que ça peut être pas
dû souvent et en 1984 vous avez 29 ans
et vous avez tourné
la france interdit qu
en
riez pas une femme libre la russe se
quittent tout symbole de l'amazone oui
bien sûr elles sont diverses images
bon je n'ai jamais revu moi une femme
nue sur un cheval pendant dix minutes
c'est un plan de fin du film
en plus le film s'appelle la france
interdit tout est fou dans cette image
c'est l'idée vous c'est une demande
qu'on arrête cette d2
jean-pierre un boris qui était qu est l
auteur notamment de joy savoure présente
bien ou pas absolument oui d'ailleurs je
continue à monter à cheval et j'adorais
l'équitation et a des cheveux
c'est à quand je suis un peu triste
angoissé malheureuse ou énervé je vous
montre sur un châle et toutous samba
quoi parce que le cheval c'est le simple
d'ailleurs le cheval c'est le symbole de
la de la libido et de la liberté absent
sur un plan symbolique de la libido
aussi oui je n'avais pas bien sûr que
j'ai tellement choses à apprendre
en tout cas quand je bosse cette image
ou à brigitte je me dis que quand
certains font la lutte des classes vous
faites la lutte du sexe la lutte pour le
corps libre
la lutte pour le plaisir et ça aussi
c'est un engagement oui et je pense
sincèrement que si les gens étaient plus
heureux dans leur vie amoureuse alors je
sanglote toujours la vie amoureuse parce
que le sexe l'amour il ya des ponts ils
sont qu'ils ont très important je pense
que la société aurait mieux je moi je
suis pas du tout libertines mai
chez les libertins ya pas tellement dans
vie il ya pas tellement de jalousie de
son voisin
je crois je crois vraiment que quand on
est bien dans son corps qu'on est bien
dans son coeur on est plus on est plus
une journée dans la lutte dans des
luttes sociales
donc vous avez tourné ses films pornos
par envie vous avez mené des émissions
de télé vous avez mené 10-7 en dentelle
radios écoutez les français qui vous
parle ce que vous continuez de faire
vous avez entendu je crois quelque chose
comme 40 mille français des experts qui
vous accompagne et qui parle de
sexualité avec vous est-ce que ce que
vous avez entendu toutes ces années ça
vous étonne
ce qui m'a beaucoup étonné c'est celle
et c'est toute la souffrance que les
gens connaissent dans leur offre les
hommes et les femmes
oui oui il y avait publié des chiffres
qui sont effrayants et seuls savent
peut-être des combats qui me qui parfois
me tente mais j'ai pas le temps mais je
trouve que je sais des combats qui me
paraissent essentiels parce que les
enfants c'est la société de demain quand
vous savez qu'il ya une femme sur quatre
et un homme sur six qui a connu des abus
sexuels avant sa majorité
saleh ça laisse quand même à penser que
c'est pas si simple d'avoir une
sexualité épanouie quand on a démarré à
buzet quoi ça devrait être le lieu de la
liberté de la créativité la sexualité
en tout cas ça devrait ça devrait être
un endroit où
on peut se retrouver parce que il ya
aussi beaucoup de pratiques sexuelles
que certains appellent des perversions
ou des des paraphilies qui sont aussi
les moyens de se réparer donc pourquoi
pas je dis oui mais jugeons pas et
écoute on est dedans
à ce que ce serait pas encore plus
victimes si vous êtes en panne est la
seule à faire ça je perds je suis pas la
seule il ya énormément de sexothérapeute
non mais allons crémant bah c'est pas si
simple à ne parler de sexualité à
l'antenne en fait c'est pour ça que
peut-être que
je pense qu'il ya quand même des
émissions sur les blogs maintenant il ya
quand même ça vous étonne pas moi ça m'a
étonné je me suis dit tiens c'est
étonnant il ya que brigitte lahaie pour
faire ça je vois qu'une il ya une
émission sur france 2 maintenant qu'ils
parlent de sexualité l'après-midi
effectués mais non mais yahia il ya des
gens comme vous soit aussi directe que
vous qu'est ce qu'il faut comme qualité
d'ailleurs pourquoi je pense que ma je
pense que même à force vous on le dira
c'est d'abord ce que je représente pour
les gens c'est à dire que c'est à dire
c'est quoi on a l'impression que comme
j'ai quand même vécu beaucoup de choses
je vais pas juger on peut tout me
raconter donc ça c'est déjà important et
c'est vrai que je peux moi je sais pas
ce qui pourrait me choquer d'ailleurs
oui à part le viol et la pédophilie moi
je dire on est entre adultes consentants
qu'est ce qui pourrait le choc et donc
les gens les gens peuvent me raconter
tout ce qu'ils ont besoin de me raconter
j'entends parfois des choses qui sont en
effet très marginale ensuite je crois
que d'abord j'ai une grande expérience
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas simplement la
connaissance sexologique ensuite j'ai
quand même aussi
pas mal de connaissances sur la
psychologie la psychanalyse même et puis
j'ai une dimension dont je parle assez
peu mais qui à mon avis est importante
dimension spirituelle qui me permet
d'entendre peut-être plus en profondeur
ce qui est dit c'est à dire c'est à dire
que
j'ai fait beaucoup d'astrologie g j'ai
étudié le cas où j'ai étudié
l'astrologie et donc je dirais presque
que j'écoute dames c'est peut-être ça
qui fait aussi ma ma force
encore une fois vous allez au delà de ce
qui est communément admis en me disant
ça maintenant
non pas que ce soit rebelles ou cocasses
mais vous n'êtes pas dans les clous vous
n'êtes pas dans les codes vous allez
encore chercher ailleurs
vous allez oui mais c'est peut-être
cette dimension là aussi qui m'a fait
m'accepter vraiment tel que je suis et
me battre jusqu'au bout parce que parce
que je ne veux pas tricher
sinon là enfin tricher c'est sortir de
son chemin mais ce qui est important
c'est pas moi pour moi réussir sa vie
c'est resté dans son chemin et est allé
au bout de ce qu'on est et aller au bout
de son vrai désir si imaginons que le
monde dans lequel vous êtes arrivé soit
un monde dans lequel le sexe n'est pas
un tabou
vous auriez mener la même vie vous
pensez d'abord ce moment de n'existera
jamais ça jamais ça n'arrivera mais non
le sexe le sexe restera forcément un
tabou puisque on a vous savez la
sexualité elle se construit de manière
cognitive et culturels donc on est
forcément
complètement baigner dans notre
éducation dans notre culture
d'ici à ce que la sexualité souhaite
libérer je pense qu'il va falloir
quelques siècles alors j'achète votre
explication mais imaginons quand même
vous auriez choisi autre chose c'est le
tabou qui vous intéresse et de défier le
tabou qui vous intéressent
ça a été la sexualité parce que c'est le
tabou des tabous qui embarrasse tout le
monde mais est ce que je me trompe si je
pense ça je sais pas je sais pas ce que
c'est c'est tellement ce qui me
passionne et qui m'intéresse que je peux
pas vous répondre ça serait à quel âge
vous avez su que ça vous passionnait la
sexualité
ça c'est une question à laquelle je peux
pas répondre mais en tout cas c'est me
suis d'abord intéressée à la sexualité
des animaux j'étais j'avais 12-13 ans
que je lisais
la sexualité des les mammifères des
oiseaux des insectes
voilà donc sans doute que ça ne m'est
mais en même temps j'ai jamais étudié
tout là toute la partie des féminines du
côté de ma mère donc je suis je veux
dire je sais je sais d'où ça vient c'est
à dire c'est le jeu le respect de leurs
aspects de je vais pas révéler des
secrets de famille et qui ne
m'appartiennent pas mais il ya des
explications aussi de ce côté là donc ça
vient de quelque part oui mais c'est un
engagement mais il ya toujours de
quelque part c'est douloureux a pas du
tout à mon nom je voulais donc très bien
non je vous parlais de secret donc on se
dit toujours quand il ya un secret c'est
que on ne dit pas les choses et quand on
n'exprime pas les choses c'est toujours
mais c'est pas c'est pas mon secret
c'est bien mais c'est le secret de ma
mère de ma grand-mère jeu et c'est ça
que vous qui vous a permis ou qui vous a
autorisé ou qui vous a fait aller sur ce
sujet réparer leurs blessures en quelque
sorte
très bien on va écouter une chanson sont
les paroles qui m'intéresse
[Musique]
vous dites ne confondons nos besoins et
nos désirs
oui c'est vrai mais on appelle souvent
c'est quand un homme dit j'ai besoin de
faire l'amour en fait c'est pas besoin à
la sexualité
on a besoin de manger on a besoin de
dormir on a besoin de boire mais on peut
on peut vivre sans faire sans faire
l'amour c'est ce serait triste mais on
peut c'est pas un besoin
et pourtant quand il dit j'ai besoin de
faire l'amour il a en fait le désir de
se sentir désiré de se sentir aimé et ça
qu'ils expriment sauf qu'ils l'expriment
en disant j'ai besoin donc la femme à
l'entendre je suis pas là quand même
pour satisfaire son besoin et d'où
l'incompréhension et c'est en ça que je
dis on confond souvent nos besoins et ne
désire parce que quand on dit j'ai
besoin de lui
derrière c'est souvent un désir mais
comme on dit j'ai besoin ça impose à
l'autre quelque part
une sorte de l'injonction qui n'a pas
lieu d'être vous n'avez jamais renoncer
à aucune envie si bien sûr bien sûr
moi j'ai été élevé dans la frustration
donc je sais ce que c'est que si
certaines désir de l'autre
et quand le de respecter le désir de
l'autre c'est parfois ne pas ne pas
aller au bout de son envie oui bien sûr
je vous pose la question parce que vous
vous exprimer et on voit que vous avez
beaucoup réfléchi beaucoup écouté
beaucoup entendu beaucoup étudié et vous
parlez aussi là on parle ensemble de
sexualité de ce que vous entendez mais
vous exprimer aussi sur les lois sur les
réglementations sur l'éducation je me
suis demandé si la politique avec plus
vous tenter un jour ou l'autre
alors là pas du tout je suis d'une
certaine manière je fais de la politique
au sens aussi sens noble du terme
eh oui que j'aide j'aide les gens de la
cité à aller mieux
la chose publique voilà la politique me
tente pas parce que parce que je crois
que de toute façon on est forcément
quand alors il ya certainement quelques
idéalistes mais dans l'absolu je pense
que la plupart des gens qui sont en
politique sont dans des relations
pouvoir et moi vraiment le le pouvoir ne
m'intéresse pas un ministère de la
sexualité par exemple ça ferait
hérétiques
oui je crois que ce serait ça serait
totalement erratique et je vraiment la
politique ne m'intéresse pas et la
politique c'est souvent être contre
l'autre ou pour l'autre enfin et cette
sorte de site c'est blanc ou c'est noir
je trouve moi je suis vraiment dans le
juste milieu et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'on qu'aucune société n'a réussi à
trouver quelque chose qui fonctionne
parce qu'on est toujours en politique
dans on est pour ou on est comme tout le
monde est contre les c
moi je suis vraiment dans ce dans le
chaos alors vous faites vous fait une
proposition politique pourtant vous avez
une idée qui a essayé d'être ni à droite
ni à gauche
en même temps on n'est pas sûr que ça
marche vous militez pour l'apprentissage
du désir l envie vous pas vous appelez
ça l'éducation affective et vous dites
on devrait enseigner l'apprentissage de
la relation à nos enfants
oui parce que comme je le disais tout à
l'heure la sexualité c'est très cognitif
et culturels et donc si dès le début on
expliqué
et des gamins
quand je dis gamin c'est gamine aussi de
trois ans un garçon c'est pas comme une
fille qu une fille c'est pas comme un
garçon que quand quand on a envie de
quelque chose il faut savoir si l'autre
en a aussi envie c'est juste des tirages
cdu c'est une mode de conduite basique
louis qui n'est pas toujours expliqué
par les parents malheureusement et qui
serait peut-être une belle manière de
recréer du lien social entre les entre
les êtres
ça pourrait s'apprendre tout jeune vous
dites que la liberté sexuelle c'est
prendre ses responsabilités et que ça ça
s'apprend quoi mais oui elle est du ksar
bien sûr à prendre ses responsabilités
le monde dans lequel nous sommes est ce
qu'il vous semble plus libre que celui
des années 70 par exemple par certains
côtés oui par d'autre part d'autres non
ce qui est un peu ennuyeux aujourd'hui
c'est je trouve qu'on a perdu beaucoup
le sens des vrais mots comme par exemple
je parle par exemple quand on va moi je
suis assez étonné tout à l'heure vous
parliez de courage je crois que pleins
il ya peu de gens qui savent que ça
vient ça la même étymologie que coeur
quand on parle par exemple de religion
d'antan tout de suite religion alors que
le religieux c'est pas c'est pas c'est
pas c'est pas la religion
du coup on tombe dans une sorte de
dogmatisme de laïcité enfin voyez toutes
ces choses là on perd un peu le sens des
mots je trouve que la langue du coup
s'appauvrit
mieux ça il ya enfin on est un peu dans
un politiquement correct ça devient très
difficile peut-être sans doute à cause
des réseaux sociaux de dire quelque
chose qui va être sorti de son contexte
et puis après on va être le la mauvaise
personne pendant 48 heures bon ça dure
de 48 heures c'est pas grave mais mais
mais du coup il ya plein de gens qui
n'ose plus dire des choses qui ont
besoin d'être dit des vérités qui sont
pas forcément faciles ni agréable à
entendre mais qui auraient besoin d'être
dites donc tout ça c'est un petit peu
c'est un petit peu après les dommages
on va donner la parole à une femme qui
elle avait une vision extrêmement claire
des choses c'est une phrase que j'ai vu
aussi dans un de vos ouvrages vous allez
pouvoir la lire c'est colette et une
femme qui se croit intelligent tu
réclames les mêmes droits que l'homme
une femme intelligente et relance est
intelligent on m'a beaucoup agressé sur
c'est quand j'ai sorti cette phrase dans
ce livret est intelligente vous je
traite de l'intelligence du coeur
après je crois que j'ai une intelligence
émotionnelle
largement au-dessus de la moyenne ce qui
m'a beaucoup aidé à m'adapter
et voilà maintenant je suis pas
quelqu'un spécialement d'intelligent au
sens de jeu pas fait d'études j'ai juste
mon bac enfin je veux dire je n'ai pas
le sentiment d'être quelqu'un de très
intelligent mais cette intelligence
comme ça de m'adapter et de ressentir
l'autre qui m'a certainement beaucoup
beaucoup aidé et qui m'a permis
d'arriver où je suis arrivé oui qu'est
ce que vous dites aux jeunes gens qui
que vous rencontrez qui je pense vous
pose la question ça vaut le coup de
s'engager ça vaut le coup d'y aller ça
vaut le coup de revendiquer la liberté
même si elle est hors des clous en tout
cas je crois que quand on est jeune
quand on a moins de 25 ans si on n'a pas
un idéal si on n'a pas une envie de
faire quelque chose c'est mal barré
oui je crois que c'est vraiment
important c'est important d'avoir des
idées aux après avec l'âge
moi j'ai plus de 60 ans il faut aussi
avoir compris que les idéaux il faut
aussi un petit peu les réviser mes mais
si on en a pas 25 ans c'est triste vous
avez révisé beaucoup à la baisse vos
idéologique non je consigne je continue
à faire ma part mais j'ai pas la
prétention de changer le monde et si
c'était à refaire et pas grand chose que
je changerais non c'est vrai j'aimerais
être peut-être un peu peu plus sûr de
moi un peu moins team et de ça se voyait
beaucoup sur l'extrait de la poste rofl
j'ai beaucoup souffert de cette sorte de
timidité de cette sorte de comme ça de
vulnérabilité cette hypersensibilité
mais aujourd'hui c'est je me rends
compte aussi que ça a été une force donc
voilà j'ai donc mais j'ai quand même pas
mal souffert donc s'affranchir du regard
de l'autre
en tout cas en tout cas ne pas ressentir
de plein fouet les critiques les
les choses désagréables qu'on entend
quand on est justement un peu en dehors
des clous merci beaucoup au président
merci monsieur
[Musique]